There lived a girl named Alice.
She had an elder sister, Mary.
One day, they were sitting by the river.
Her sister was reading a book with big words and no pictures.
The sun is nice and warm, but I'm so bored.
Why don't you take a nap?
Um... That's a good idea!
Alice saw a white rabbit running past when she was about to fall asleep.
The rabbit pulled a watch from his coat pocket and said,...
"...I'm too late! I have a very important date."
Huh? How strange!
She watched as the rabbit ran into a strange hole.
I wonder where he's going.
I want to follow him.
Alice crawled into the hole.
Soon, she was falling and falling.
She landed safely and looked around.
After a while, she found a small door in the hall.
She looked outside through the keyhole.
Oh, what a beautiful garden!
I wish I could go there.
Alice was far too big to fit through the small door.
Then, she saw a glass bottle labeled 'Drink Me' and a key on the table.
What are they?
She saw no sign that read 'Poison' so she drank the bottle.
Oh, what's happening? I'm shrinking!
Soon, she became small enough to fit through the door.
Oops.... I forgot to take the key!
She tried to climb the table leg but she was too small to reach it.
Huh? What's this?
There was a small box labeled 'Eat Me' under the table.
Alice opened it and found a small cake.
If it makes me bigger, maybe I can get the key.
Alice quickly ate the cake.
Then she grew so big, her head hit the ceiling.
Now I can't fit through the door!
She cried and cried.